[Music]
[Music]
everybody stop episode eight gosh the
first film didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
[Music]
some of the stuff that happens people
gonna be like oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things have me story-wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like its own thing
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures
all these amazing visual effects
but all the characters are also so
complex
Ryan Mesa welcomes Wilkie sells
ridiculous new director only business
Lana wiki sound
[Music]
it feels like the storylines becoming
more established
we're really getting to know these new
characters also with the characters that
we know and love
man I've change
everything's being shifted in the
opposite way to what the audio is
expected after seven
Brian's made Star Wars fresh and new
[Music]
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the fermentation story of good against
evil
told in the most fascinating way but it
has a real spiritual depth to it
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
you